CBS News Chief Little glennless John
Dickerson joins us at the table John we
couldn't think of a better person to be
at the table at this moment we're really
glad you're here you know for we've
heard the word unprecedented with Donald
Trump from the very beginning from the
time he came down that escalator at
Mar-A-Lago and here we sit all these
years later still calling it an
unprecedented moment put into context
for us how significant this really is
well when you use a word that much it
loses all meaning which is in part
something we should talk about and think
about it with former president Trump
because that's in part part of his
strategy is that you know if everybody's
always hopped up nothing becomes
differentiated and he can say well this
is just like everybody else but it's not
like everybody else what he's accused of
is very serious the documents he is
accused of keeping uh are some of the
most sensitive if not the most sensitive
documents that are in the the part of
the federal system he's he's accused of
obstructing justice after he received a
subpoena that is a big deal we've
mentioned of course the biggest deal
which is the first former president to
be federally charged but also this is a
president who is being charged with
something that his former opponent in
2016 Hillary Clinton was was accused of
doing
and he beat her because of it yeah so I
mean when you think of the the
historical parallels that's also
something that adds to the complexity
and richness of this moment there's a
Donald Trump quote for every occasion of
course and since you mentioned 2016 back
then the tune that he was singing is I'm
going to enforce all laws concerning the
protection of classified information no
one will be above the law we're in a
different place now we are in a
different place his party is is largely
rallying around him and and we don't
know the facts of the case yet this is
another one of those instances where we
are all stewards of our system and we
all have to be very careful because we
don't know what the facts are and yet a
lot of people including the house
Speaker are rushing in and saying this
is a political politicization that it's
a weaponization Ron DeSantis the Florida
governor said that
um we don't know and and you know it's
not only the retention of records and
the possible dissemination of
information that's the most highly
sensitive but it's also obstruction of
justice when you receive a subpoena you
can't lie about whether you've answered
the subpoena you're not supposed to in
the in the system in one of the Bedrock
principles is that everybody is straight
did the same so the lieutenant colonel
has gone to jail for three years because
of Records he kept is kept is is treated
the same way as a former president in
the American system that's one of the
things at issue here Sir John you
mentioned some of the Republican
candidates for the presidency who are
all talking about the weaponization of
the Department of Justice but there are
two Chris Christie ASA Hutchinson uh who
have called this for what many believe
it to be uh Chris Christie says no one
is above the law uh will that work with
primary voters with independent voters
who are maybe you said something
interesting the fact that every time
president Trump faces a situation like
this he says it's a hoax it loses all
meaning
Witch Hunt are independent voters tired
of that and are maybe looking for
something different we we don't know yet
um one of the things that was
interesting about the Hillary Clinton
case in 2016 is when issues were raised
about her emails one of the things that
analysts said is you know it reminded
voters that that if Hillary Clinton gets
elected there'll just be a lot of
michigas of her presidency you could
easily see that being the case here with
President Trump and about Ron DeSantis
and others who have essentially raised
that point previously basically we don't
want a lot of drama so that could be
something that's a that's a part of this
what's been interesting to me is the
Continuum of candidates so as you
mentioned ASA Hutchinson said this is
proof that Donald Trump should not run
Mike Pence said this is divisive but
before this information came out he said
Donald Trump shouldn't be president
again because of what he did on January
6th this information comes out in a
different context you have a bunch of
people in the Republican Party who are
saying he should not be president again
and this trial will go on well into the
primary well maybe even in the general
election and so it will be a constant
source of conversation as people discuss
issues like character what does it mean
to uh you know obey the law and and that
changes this from the previous trouble
it does it's interesting how people say
should not be president again but when
pushed would you support him if he was a
nominee
in some cases I said yes I would still
support them that's very confusing it's
very confusing it's also a little tricky
because the rules of the Republican
debate are that you have to say you're
going to support the nominee so there
might be a little cutesiness that there
that those other Republican candidates
are playing but it is one of the intent
internal tensions here is that at the
one hand these other candidates are
trying to court Donald Trump's voters by
saying they support him but they're
doing so in order hopefully to beat him
all right John Dickerson I know this
won't be the last time you'll be at the
table and I can't wait
they call them the great John Dickerson
for a reason just saying I think you're
the only one who calls now everybody
agrees chat about it we have a census
you know six years
me and your wife yes yeah well the kids
are going to call and file a complaint
you will hear much more from John
Dickerson on the Trump indictment this
Sunday on Face the Nation